This lecture is about the text
retrieval problem.
This picture shows our overall plan for
lectures.
In the last lecture we talked about the
high level strategies for text access.
We talked about push versus pull.
Search engines are the main tools for
supporting the pull mode.
Starting from this lecture, we're going
to talk about how the search engines
work in detail.
So first it's about the text retrieval
problem.
We are going to talk about three things
in this lecture.
First, we'll define text retrieval.
Second, we're going to make a comparison
between text retrieval and the related
task, database retrieval.
Finally, we're going to talk about the
document selecting versus document
ranking as two strategies for
responding to a users query.
So what is text retrieval?
It should be a task that's familiar to
most of us because we're using web
search engines all the time.
So text retrieval is basically
a task where the system would respond
to a user's query with relevant
documents.
Basically, to support the query.
As one way to implement the pull mode
of information access.
So the scenario is the following you have a
collection of text documents.
These documents could be all the web
pages on the web.
Or all the literature articles in the
digital library.
Or maybe all the text files in your
computer.
A user will typically give a query to
the system to express information need
and then the system would return
relevant documents to users. Relevant
documents
refer to those documents that are
useful to the user who is in typing the
query.
Now this task is often called
information retrieval.
But literally, information retrieval
would broadly include retrieval of
other non textual information as well.
For example audio, video etc.
It's worth noting that text retrieval is
at the core of information retrieval,
in the sense that other medias, such as
video, can be retrieved by exploiting
the companion text data.
So for example.
Current image search engines.
Actually match the users query with the
companion text data of the image.
This problem is also called the search
problem.
And the technology is often called
search technology in industry.
If you have to take a course in
databases.
It will be useful to pause the lecture
at this point.
And think about.
The differences between text retrieval
and database retrieval.
Are these two tasks are similar in many
ways?
But there are some important
differences.
So spend a moment to think about the
differences between the two.
Think about the data and information
managed by search engine versus those
that are managed by a database system.
Think about the difference between the
queries that you typically specify for
a database system.
Versus the queries that are typed in by
users on the search engine.
And then finally, think about the
answers.
What's the difference between the two?
OK, so if we think about the
information or data managed by the two
systems, we will see that.
In text retrieval, the data is
unstructured free text, but in
databases.
They are structured data where there is
a clear definer schema to tell you.
This column is the names of people in
that column is ages, etc.
In unstructured text it's not obvious
what are the names of people mentioned
in the text.
Because of this difference, we can also
see that text information tends to be
more ambiguous, and we talked about
that in the natural language processing
lecture.
Whereas in databases that data tended
to have well defined the semantics.
There is also important difference in
the queries.
And this is partly due to the
difference in the information.
Or data.
So text queries tend to be ambiguous.
Where as in database search.
The queries are typically well defined.
Think about the SQL query that would
clearly specify what records to be
returned so it has very well defined
semantics.
Keyword queries or natural language
queries tend to be incomplete also.
In that it doesn't really fully
specify what document should be
retrieved.
Where as in the database search.
The SQL query can be regarded as a
computer specification for what should
be returned.
And because of these differences, the
answers will be also different.
In the case of texy retrieval, we're
looking for relevant documents.
In the database search we are
retrieving records or match records
with.
The SQL query more precisely.
Now, in the case of tax retrieval, what
should be the right answers to a query
is not very well specified as we just
discussed.
So it's unclear what should be the
right answers to a query, and this has
very important consequences and that is
text retrieval is an empirically defined
problem.
So this is.
A problem because.
If it's empirically defined.
Then we cannot mathematically prove one
method is better than another method.
That also means we must rely on
empirical evaluation involving users.
To know which method works better.
And that's why we have a lecture,
actually more than one lectures to
cover the issue of evaluation.
Because this is a very important topic
for search engines.
Without knowing how to evaluate the algorithm
appropriately, there's no way to tell
whether we have got a better algorithm
or whether one system is better than
another.
So now let's look at the problem in a
formal way.
So this slide shows a formal
formulation of the text retrieval
problem.
First, we have our vocabulary set.
Which is just a set of words in a
language.
Now here.
We are considering just one language,
but in reality on the web there might
be multiple natural languages.
We have text data in all kinds of
languages.
But here for simplicity, we just assume
there is one kind of language as the
techniques used for retrieving data
from multiple languages are more or less
similar to the techniques used for
retrieving documents in one language.
Although there is important difference,
the principles and methods are.
very similar.
Next we have the query, which is a
sequence of words.
And so here.
You can see.
The.
Query.
Is defined as a sequence of words.
Each q sub I is a word in the
vocabulary.
A document is defined in the same way,
so it's also a sequence of words and
here d sub ij.
is also a word in the vocabulary.
Now typically the documents are much
longer than queries.
But there are also cases where.
The documents may be very short.
So you can think about what might be an
example of that case.
I hope you can think of Twitter search
right tweets are very short.
But in general, documents are longer
than the queries.
Now then we have a collection of
documents.
And this collection can be very large,
so think about the web.
It could could be very large.
And then the goal of text retrieval is
to find the set of relevant
documents which we denoted by R of Q
because it depends on the query and
this is in general a subset of all the
documents in the collection.
Unfortunately, this set of relevant
documents is generally unknown.
And user dependent in the sense that
for the same query typed in by different
users.
The expected relevant documents may be
different.
The query given to us by the user is
only a hint on which document should be
in this set.
And indeed, the user is generally
unable to specify what exactly should
be in this set, especially in the case
of web search.
Where collection is so large the user
doesn't have complete knowledge about
the whole collection.
So the best a search system can do.
Is to compute an approximation of this
relevant document.
set so we denote by r prime of Q.
So formally, we can see the task is to
compute this r prime of Q, an
approximation of the relevant
documents.
So how can we do that?
Imagine if you are now asked to write a
program to do this.
What would you do now?
Think for a moment.
Right, so these are your input.
the query the documents.
And then you are to compute the answers
to this query.
Which is a set of documents that would
be useful to the user.
So how would you solve the problem?
Now, in general.
There are two strategies that we can
use.
The first strategies will do document
selection and that is we're going to
have a binary classification function
or binary classifier.
That's a function that would take a
document and query as input.
And then give a zero or one as output
to indicate whether this document is
relevant to the query or not.
So in this case you can see the
document.
The relevant document in the set is
defined as follows, it basically.
All the documents that.
Have a value of 1 by this function.
And so in this case you can see the
system must decide if a document is
relevant or not.
Basically it has to say whether it's
one or zero.
And this is called absolute relevance.
Basically it needs to know exactly
whether it's going to be useful to the
user.
Alternatively, there's another strategy
called document ranking.
Now, in this case the system is not
going to make a call whether a document
is relevant or not, but rather the
system is going to use the real value
function F here.
That would simply give us a value that
would indicate which document is more
likely relevant.
So it's not going to make a call
whether this document is relevant or
not, but rather it would say which
document is more likely relevant.
So this function then can be used to
rank the documents.
And then we're going to let the user
decide where to stop when the user
looks at the documents.
So we have a threshold.
See down here.
To determine what documents should be
in this approximation, set.
And we can assume that all the
documents that are ranked above this
threshold are in this set.
Be cause in effect, these are the
documents that we deliver to the user.
And theta is a cut off determined by the
user.
So here we've got some collaboration
from the user in some sense, because we
don't really make a cut off and the
user kind of helped the system make a
cut off.
So in this case the system only needs
to decide if one document is more
likely relevant than another, and that
is it only needs to determine relative
relevance.
As opposed to absolute relevance.
Now you can probably already sense
that.
Relevant relative relevance would be
easier to determine their absolute
relevance because in the first case, we
have to say exactly whether a document
is relevant or not.
And it turns out that ranking is indeed
generally preferred to document
selection.
So let's look at this.
These two strategies in more detail.
So this picture shows how it works.
So on the left side we see these
documents and we use the pluses.
To indicate the relevant documents so
we can see the true relevant documents
here.
This is.
This set of two random documents
consist of these pluses these
documents.
And with the document selection.
Functioning we are going to do basically
classify them into two groups, relevant
documents and non relevant ones.
Of course the classifier will not be
perfect so it will make mistakes.
So here we can see in the approximation
of the relevant documents we have got
some non relevant documents.
And similarly there is a relevant
document that's miss classified as non
relevant.
In the case of document ranking, we can
see the system seems like simply ranks
all the documents in the descending
order of the scores.
And then we're going to let the users
stop wherever the user wants to stop.
So if a user wants to examine more
documents, then the user would go down
the list to examine more and stop at
the lower position.
But if the user only wants to read a
few relevant documents, the user might
stop at the top position.
So in this case the user stops at d4
so in effect we have delivered
these four documents.
To our user.
So as I said, ranking is generally
preferred.
An one of the reasons is because the
classifier.
In the case of document selection is
unlikely accurate. Why?
Because the only clue is usually the
query, but query may not be accurate in
the sense that it could be overly
constrained.
For example, you might expect the
relevant documents to talk about all
these.
Topics you by using specific vocabulary
and as a result.
You might.
Match no random documents because in
the collection no others have discussed the topic
using these vocabularies.
So in this case you will see there is
this problem of.
No relevant documents to return in the
case of overly constraint query.
On the other hand, if the query is
underconstrained, for example.
If the query does not have sufficient
discriminating words to find the
relevant documents, you may actually
end up having over delivery.
And this is when you thought these
words might be sufficient to help you
find the relevant documents.
But it turns out that they are not
sufficient, and there are many
distraction documents using similar
words.
Right so.
This is the case of over delivery.
Unfortunately, it's very hard to find
the right position between these two
extremes.
Why cause when the user is looking for
the information?
In general, the user does not have a
good knowledge about the information to
be found.
And in that case the user does not have
a good knowledge about what.
Vocabularies will be used in those
random documents.
So it's very hard for user to pre
specify the right level of constraints.
Even if the classifier is accurate.
We also still want to rank these red
documents because.
They are generally not equally
relevant.
Relevance is often a matter of degree.
So we must prioritize.
These documents for a user to examine.
And this note that this prioritization
is very important.
Because a user cannot digest all the
contents at once, the user general
would have to look at each document
sequentially.
And therefore it would make sense to
feed the users with the most relevant
documents.
And that's what ranking is doing.
So For these reasons, ranking is
generally preferred now.
This preference also has a theoretical
justification, and this is given by the
probability ranking principle.
In the end of this lecture there is
reference for this.
This principle says returning a ranked
list of documents in descending order
of probability that a document is
relevant to the query is the optimal
strategy under the following two
assumptions.
First, the utility of the document to a
user is independent of the utility of
any other document.
2nd, a user would be assumed to browse
the results sequentially.
Now it's easy to understand why these
two assumptions are needed in order to
justify for the ranking strategy.
because if the documents are
independent then we can evaluate the
utility of each document separately.
And this would allow us to compute the
score for each document independently,
and then we're going to rank these
documents based on those scores.
The second assumption is to say that
the user would indeed follow the ranked
list if the user is not going to follow
the ranked list is not going to examine
the documents sequentially, then
obviously the ordering would not be
optimal.
So under these two assumptions.
We can theoretically justify the
rankings strategy is in fact the best
you could do.
Now I've put one question here.
Do these two assumptions hold?
Now I suggest you to pause the lecture
for a moment to think about this.
Now, can you think of some examples?
That would suggest.
These
Assumptions aren't necessarily true.
Now, if you think for a moment you may
realize.
None of the assumptions is actually
true.
For example, in the case of
independence assumption.
We might have identical documents that
have similar content or exactly the
same content.
If you look at each of them alone.
Each is relevant.
But if the user has already seen one of
them.
We assume it's generally not very
useful for the user to see another
similar or duplicated one.
So clearly the utility of document is
dependent on other documents that user
has seen.
In some other cases you might see a
scenario where one document that may
not be useful to the user, but when
three particular documents are put
together, they provide answer to the
users question.
So this is a collective relevance and
that also suggests that the value of
the document might depend on other
documents.
Sequential browse in general would make
sense if you have a ranked list there.
But even if you have a ranked list.
There was evidence showing that users
don't always just go strictly
sequentially through the entire list.
There sometimes would look at the
bottom, for example, or skip some.
And if you think about the more
complicated interface that we could
possibly use, like 2 dimensional
interface where you can put the
additional information on the screen,
then seek when you're browsing is a
very restrictive assumption.
So the point here is that.
None of these assumptions is really
true.
But nevertheless.
The probability ranking principle
established some solid foundation for
ranking as a primary task for search
engines.
This has actually been the basis for a
lot of research work in information
retrieval, and many algorithms have
been designed based on this assumption
Despite that.
The assumptions aren't necessarilly true and we
can address this problem by doing post
processing of a ranked list, for
example to remove redundancy.
So to summarize this lecture, the main
points.
That you can take away are the
following.
First text retrieval is an empirical
defined problem.
And that means which algorithm is better must
be judged by the users.
Second, document ranking is generally
preferred.
And this will help users prioritize
examination of search results.
And this is also to bypass the
difficulty in determining absolute
relevance.
Because we can get some help from
users in determining where to make the
cut off.
It's more flexible.
So this further suggests that the main
technical challenge in designing search
engine is redesigned effective ranking
function.
In other words, we need to define what
is the value of this function F on.
The query and document pair.
The whole design.
Such a function is the main topic in
the following lectures.
There are two suggested additional
readings.
The first is the classic paper on
probability ranking principle.
The second is a must read for anyone
doing research information travel.
It's a classic IR book.
Which has excellent coverage of the
main research results in early days.
Up to the time when the book was
written, Chapter 6 of this book has in
depth discussion of the probability
ranking principle and probabilistic
retrieval models in general.